what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thsy and House
of the Dragon update video in this video
I'll be revealing more information about
House of the Dragon second season I now
have a better understanding of what's
happening in the new season after
watching House of the Dragon official
teaser over and over again I've already
made one breakdown video where I
described what I believe is happening in
each of the new scenes now I want to
have a second look at the video with all
of you because I've made some new
discoveries in regards to the upcoming
season of the show I want to start off
by describing what will happen in the
first episode then I'll work my way back
to the finale of House of the Dragons
new season now before we get started I
have to let all of you know about this
amazing new offer I'd like to thank the
sponsor of today's video raycon rayon's
Everyday earbuds were a lifechanger for
me when I first got mine I'm not even
exaggerating when I say I wear them for
about 8 hours every day and the battery
always lasts for a really long time I
like wearing mine to listen to my
favorite shows while I clean and work
out and I use them to edit all of my
videos and I even fall asleep with them
still in my ears most nights what's
great about these are they're incredibly
lightweight and comfortable while still
fitting snugly in my ear not to mention
the audio quality is amazing and I just
love their noise isolating feature right
now is the perfect time to get on board
with raycon if you haven't already they
have recently expanded their business by
introducing raycon home and raycon
Powertech products including the magic
180 charging cable and their new faucet
filter they've already earned themselves
tens of thousands of five-star reviews
and now they're universally useful and
the best last minute Christmas gift they
also offer easy and free returns as well
as free shipping and buy now pay later
options this holiday season get premium
sound at a great price and save even
more by doing it now go to by ron.com
Thrones to get 15% off sitewide and
support my channel in the process once
again that's bu ron.com Thrones to get
15% off sitewide you don't want to miss
out on this amazing offer thanks again
to raycon for sponsoring today's
video
all right now let's have a look at what
will happen in the first episode of the
new season you've actually already seen
where the season will begin if you've
watched HBO's new video we will see rera
overlooking shipbreaker Bay right
outside of storms Zen where her son died
at the end of last season as you all
know this is where her son lucar valyon
died after vagar devoured him and his
Dragon above the bay there was a shot of
some of the fishermen on the shore of
shipbreaker bay maybe they found his
body and brought it ashore or maybe they
simply let rira know what they saw out
there no one is really sure if rira will
actually see the body of her son or his
Dragon floating in the water but by the
look on her face it seems her worst fear
is confirmed Luc car's valyon is dead
and it will only be one of many shocking
events that happen during the dance of
the Dragons now if you have red fire and
blood then you know this is when Damon
sends rira a letter from heren Hall
demanding Vengeance for her son in that
letter Damon says he wants a son for a
son that's actually what they name name
the first episode now House of the
Dragon will look slightly different from
what George wrote in Fire and Blood as
you all know Damon wasn't at heren Hall
when they learn of Luke's death in the
show he was still on Dragon stone with
reneer when they found out now instead
of sending a letter we will see Damon
have this conversation with rira before
he leaves Dragon Stone once again he
will demand a son for a son and that's
when we should see Damon send Ward to
masara or maybe even someone else to
have Assassin sent into the red ke for
Revenge I believe that's what we see
them discussing in the new scene right
here here we have riro holding a small
black council meeting on Dragon Stone
since Damon will be gone for most of the
season I have to believe they're having
that conversation in this scene while
he's still there then we're going to see
Damon Le for heren Hall before the
episode is over we've also heard that we
will see Winterfell in this first
episode as well Rene's other son Jar's
valyon will be flying to Winterfell this
season after he makes stops in the veil
in white Harbor jakary will be on his
way to Winterfell to make an alliance
with how Stark the opening scene at
Winterfell may give us the introduction
to Lord crean Stark before Jace arrives
I don't think we're going to see Jace
there this soon unless they have him
arrive in the veil in white Harbor
afterwards now before the episode is
over we will see one of the most
shocking moments from this season that's
when blood and cheese will enter the red
keep and attack Helena and her sons
there's a great shot of this scene right
here as Helena has a blade held to her
neck if you actually enhance the image
it looks as if they've already drawn
some blood Helena will unfortunately
have to decide what Sun they will
execute I imagine this scene and even
the episode will have the internet on
fire after it's over I will be
interested to see how the fans react to
Damon knowing he was the one who ordered
the hit now in The Following episode we
will see the funeral ceremony held
throughout the city they will ride
through the streets of King's Landing as
everyone Mourns the loss of aegon and
Helena's small son in this shot of
Helena you can see some burning embers
floating in the air that's most likely
while they're burning his body after
they've rode through King's Landing now
it seems there may be a riot in King's
Landing during the scene if you look at
the dress Allison is wearing during the
funeral it looks to be the same one
she's wearing as she's running for her
life I've heard the riot is most likely
over food or the lack thereof once again
the residents of King's Landing are
starving and they want to be fed by
those who have the money I actually
thought this might happen later in the
season but after looking at what they're
wearing I think it might happen in the
second episode we'll have to wait and
see how the scene actually unfolds after
the death of little Jar's aegon will
want revenge himself they will send Eric
cargo to Dragonstone disguised as his
brother that's when these brothers will
face off against each other till the
death very similar to the clean brothers
and Game of Thrones we're also going to
see a small battle in the second episode
as well this will be the battle at
Burning Mill when the Brackin fight the
blackwoods it was actually sort of set
up in the first season when we saw
Willam Blackwood fight the man from
house Bracken in front of rera while she
was at Storm's end this will be the
first official Battle of the dance of
the Dragons now we are going to see
Damon capture harrenhal but there won't
be a battle because they're not ready to
face his Dragon unfortunately I don't
have any solid information for what will
happen in the third episode that might
be the episode where we see Damon behead
someone under the werewell or this might
be the episode where we see the knight's
watch by episode three Jace will have
arrived in Winterfell and made friends
with Lord C and Stark we know they're
going to go to the wall together to
visit the knight's watch I think episode
3 sounds about right since there's
already so much happening in the first
and second episodes now episode four
will be a banger because that's when
we're going to see the first major
battle at rook's rest first we will see
the sack duskendale where sir Kristen
Cole beheads Lord darkland for siding
with rira afterwards we will see their
armies marching to the field at Rooks
rest where all hell will break loose the
battle might be very reminiscent of the
field of fire in Game of Thrones when
Daenerys Burns the Lannister Army only
this will be much bigger since there
will be three dragons at the Battle
before it's all said and done this is
where we're going to get the money shot
of aan riding on vagar as they're about
to face off against rainy and her Dragon
melees it will be one hell of a sight to
see as zon and his Dragon Sunfire join
the fight as well it will be unlike
anything we've ever seen before a dragon
will die while another is injured badly
not only that but aegon suffers injuries
that will keep him off the iron throne
for quite some time that's when we're
going to see Amon one eye Ascend the
iron throne in the fifth episode as
aegon is healing from his injuries
suffered in that battle episode 5 is
also when we should see another ceremony
held in King's Landing when the dragon
set is displayed for all to see now
outside of this there's not a whole lot
of information about what's going to
happen in the fifth episode most of the
shots from HBO's first official teaser
are from the first four episodes
hopefully we will see more from the
other episodes when they release their
full trailer I don't have much
information about episode 6 either that
might be the episode where the dragon
seeds get burned alive on Dragon Stone
after they tried mounting the dragons we
know some of them will burn because a
dragon won't allow just anyone to mount
them even if they do have some Dragon
blood in their veins now episode 7 will
have a mysterious shot of Allison as
she's standing by the lake no one has
been able to confirm where this actually
is in Westeros we just know it's going
to happen in episode 7 many fans believe
Allison is standing out there to mourn a
loss or maybe and ask for forgiveness
for what's happened I don't know but I'm
very interested in finding out we'll
also see Adam of Hall swear filty to
rera in this episode that's where we see
rera and Cyrax on the beach in front of
Adam of Hall and his new dragon sea
smoke if you remember sea smoke was the
dragon of Lor valeron before he faked
his death and fled Westeros well now
that he's gone Adam of Hall will be
riding his Dragon into battle for rera
this is why I think we will see the
dragon seeds burn in episode six because
Adam of Hall has already mounted sea
smoke and swore filty to rera by episode
7 unfortunately there's only going to be
eight episodes in this season in the
final episode rira and Damon will
reunite at harrenhal we'll also finally
see L corus valeron as well who will
mostly be absent during the season he
will be leaving his home of drift Mark
and full battle armor as he heads into
battle we're not going to see until the
third season it sucks we won't see the
battle and the goet this season but at
least we know we still have something
great to look forward to in the third
after all the battle in the gallet is
known as one of the bloodiest sea
battles in Westeros SE history I'll be
very excited to finally see the Seas
snake and all of his glory right before
he loses nearly onethird of his massive
Fleet although the second season will be
shorter I believe the episodes will be
far more exciting and interesting than
what we've seen so far I know I'm not
the only one who's ready to watch them
right now let me know what you think
about these episodes down below what are
you excited to see
as always I want to thank all of you for
watching another video I hope all of you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon
[Music]
bye